- So I have an infinite series, here.
The sum from n equals zero
to infinity of negative one
to the n power times x to the sixth n
over two n, the whole two n, factorial.
And my goal in this video is
to evaluate this power series
when x is equal to the
cubed root of pi over two.
And I encourage you to pause this video
and give it a go on your own.
And I will give you a hint.
The key to this is to figure out,
well what function is
this the power series for?
and then use that
function to evaluate this.
And there's another clue here, hey,
this is kind of a
mysterious or a suspicious
looking number, here, pi over two.
That looks like something I would use
a trig function to evaluate.
That might be a little
bit more straightforward.
So I'll let you have a go at it.
So I'm assuming you have tried,
so let's try to work
through this together.
And in any of these types of problems
I like to at least expand
out this power series
so I get a better sense of what it's like.
So this right over here,
if I were to expand it out,
this is going to be
equal to when n is zero,
this is one, actually,
all of these are one,
so it's just going to be one.
When n is one, this is going to be
negative one, x to the sixth,
x to the sixth over two factorial.
when n is two, it's going to be positive.
negative one squared is positive one,
times x to the 12th over four factorial.
and then let's just do one
more: when x is equal to three,
it's going to be negative x to the 18th.
x to the 18th over six factorial.
And you just keep going on and on forever.
Now, offhand, I don't know a function,
especially a trigonometric function,
because that was kind of our clue here,
this pi over two makes me feel like
this might be a trigonometric
function right over here
Nothing jumps out at me offhand,
but this does look suspiciously familiar.
This looks awfully close
to the power series,
or the Maclaurin Series for cosine of x.
Which we have seen multiple times.
Let's just remind
ourselves of what that is.
And if this doesn't look familiar,
the previous video where
I do the Maclaurin Series
for cosine of x goes into
detail on how I get this.
The Maclaurin Series for
cosine of x is equal to...
So I'll just write a few terms,
so I'll write approximately equal to
one minus x squared over two factorial,
plus x to the fourth over four factorial,
minus x to the sixth over six factorial,
and just like that you're
probably seeing the similarities.
Well the first term is the same,
the sign negative, positive,
negative, positive,
negative, positive, negative, positive.
two factorial, four
factorial, six factorial.
The difference is the powers,
the exponents on the x.
This is x squared, this is x to the sixth.
This is x to the fourth,
that's x to the 12th.
This is x to the sixth,
that's x to the 18th.
Well, what if we...
I guess, something for
you to think about is,
well, how can we replace
x with something here?
Because anything that I change,
if I take cosine of...
if I change x to, I don't know, a plus b,
everywhere we see an x, you'd
replace it with an a plus b.
Can we put a power of x here,
so that these things end up like that?
well, this x to the
sixth is the same thing,
as x to the third squared.
That's x to the third squared.
This right over here, x to the 12th,
is the same thing as x to the
third to the fourth power.
This right over here is the same thing as
x to the third to the sixth power.
So if we could replace each of
these xs with x to the thirds
we will get this power series up here.
Well, how do we do that?
Well, we would just say the
cosine of x to the third
and actually let me do
that in a different color.
So the cosine, and that's
not a different color.
So the cosine of x to the
third is going to be equal to,
and once again, everywhere we see an x,
we replace it with x to the third.
So it's one minus, and actually,
I'm just going to put in
parenthesis squared, two factorial.
I wanted to do that in the green,
let me do all this in the green.
Alright, so it's gonna be equal to:
one minus parenthesis
squared over two factorial
plus parenthesis to the fourth
power over four factorial.
minus parenthesis to the
sixth power over 6 factorial.
And now let me change
back to that mauve color.
And since I'm taking the
cosine of x to the third,
well this is gonna be
x to the third squared.
this is gonna be x to the
third to the fourth power.
third to the sixth power.
Which is exactly what
I have right over here.
So this right over here
is the power series
for cosine of x to the third.
So evaluating this when x is equal to
the cubed root of pi over two,
is the same thing as evaluating this
when x is equal to the
cubed root of pi over two.
Let me write that down,
because this is interesting.
So this, so I'll just rewrite
it, from n equals zero
to infinity of negative one to the n
of x to the sixth n over two n factorial.
This is equal to, this is the
power series representation,
of cosine of x to the third power.
So if you want to evaluate this
when x is the cubed root of pi over two,
we just have to evaluate this
when x is the cubed root of pi over two.
And this does suspiciously
work out nicely,
because if you take the
cube of the cubed root,
well, good things happen.
So the cosine of the
cubed root of pi over two
to the third power, well
that's just the same thing
as cosine of pi over two,
which, of course, is equal to zero.
And we are done.